la terre brûlée sous mes pieds et Je Ne
sais je ne sais pas
[Musique]
m'arrêter Je Ne fais lui que passer Oh
oui Je suis chez Moi o on mme ailleurs
ailleurs Je suis un étranger Oh oui de
trains en train et de Ville en Ville Je
trouve enfin ton chemin vers une autre ville
notre H et une autre fille a aimer et Je
Ne me souviens plus d'elle et son nom Je
l'ai oublié Oh oui Je cours toujours
après l'amour mais la vie va me rattraper
Oh oui la terre promise n'est pas
toujours o l'on cit bien la
[Musique]
trouver
j'ai utilisé ma fri et mes potes sur les
routes du monde
entier j'ai chanté Plus de chansons que
vous en avez écouté Oh oui j'ai cru
trouve la terre promise quand j'ai cru
J'ai trouvé mon amour davantage et Ai laisse oui
ma chemise et je suis reparti un jour Oh
oui de solitude en solitude Je finirai
bonne paire
trouver avant de perdre l'habitude de
conjuguer le verbe aimer Oh oui la PR
est la terre promise je cours je cours
après depuis toujours oui tant pis si J
J'ai perdu ma route si je trouvais mon chemin
l'amour Oh oui la terre brûlée sous mes
pieds et Je Ne sais Je Ne sais pas
on m'entraîne et Je Ne fais que passer
Oh oui Je suis chez Moi o on ae ailleurs
ailleurs je suis un
étranger de train en train et de Ville
in Ville Je finirai bien par
[Musique]
trouver